hey everyone james murphy here with m
coding in this video we're talking about
method chaining this design pattern is
not specific to python and you may also
see it referred to as method cascading
or using a fluent api
here we have a simple player class
player has a name a position and a level
of fatigue we can draw players move
players and let them rest so let's
create a player
i make a player james
then move him up right up let him rest
and then draw
there's nothing wrong with doing things
this way and this is how i usually do it
but look how much of this code is just
repeating the word james
this is a verb driven api move rest and
draw all just return none
so how about instead we make them all
return self
then each of these methods returns the
james object back to me so now i can
delete these
and do this
now all the repeated information is gone
you can put all the calls on separate
lines if you use line continuations
or if you wrap everything in an extra
pair of parens then you don't need line
continuations and this is the style i
see most common in the wild just keep in
mind that in order to convert an api
into this form all of the methods had to
return none
this kind of api works because each of
these methods is a verb that mutates the
underlying object and there's also a
variant of this pattern for immutable
objects you're probably familiar with
the idea even if you haven't explicitly
used it here i have some random text
then all chained together i can say take
the text strip it uppercase it and
center it and python strings are
immutable so instead of actually
stripping the string it returns a
stripped copy of the string and likewise
the other methods return some kind of
modified copy of their self parameter
here's an example how to code a class
with method chaining support using
copies
i've got a basic xyz vector
and normalized returns the same vector
but scale down to unit length just
compute the length of the vector then
construct a new object of the same type
as self of course pass in the modified
arguments and the same kind of thing
goes for a reflected vector
now we can create a vector 1 2 3
and i can get a reflected normalized
copy
because we made a copy our p and q are
different
if reflected and normalized modified the
original vector and then returned self
then they would be the same
of course there's always a penalty if
you're making copies of things but there
are also benefits to making things
immutable so this is a trade-off that
you get to decide
how about a real and useful example of
where this actually shows up
here i have two sql alchemy database
models
my user model has an idea name and a
full name
and the address model has an id email
address and the user id that the email
address corresponds to
straight from the docs look how we can
pick out an email address
we start with a select address this
creates a select object
a select object models a select
statement that you're going to send to
the database to get information back
at any point in the process we can print
the select statement and see the sql
that it corresponds to
so here we have a select id email
address user id from the address table
when i uncomment the join now i have
join text on the end of the query
every time i apply another method i get
back another select object with a more
detailed query
this is method chaining at work and it
makes creating sql queries really easy
in python
how about a data science example
here's some sample sales data across
four different months for three
different companies
using plain old pandas you might write
code that looks something like this
first we create a data frame object from
the sales data
we don't really care about company 1 so
we delete it we know there are some
nands in there and for this analysis we
don't want to use them so we'll drop
them
oh and these aren't just company 2 and 3
it's actually amazon and facebook so
let's rename and the google data was
stored somewhere else so let's go ahead
and add it in then we go ahead and
proceed to do whatever data analysis we
were going to do there's nothing
necessarily wrong with this code but
it's still kind of just hard to read
enter pie janitor it's a library that
you can pip install and it provides a
method chaining verb-based interface to
pandas data frames
now the same operations as before can be
done in a much cleaner and more uniform
way
i hope you can agree that this is a lot
easier to read than the previous example
i load my dictionary i remove a column i
drop the nands i rename a column i
rename another and then i add a column
and that's all there is to it it's all
the same functions as before or you can
define your own and it just provides an
easy way to kind of create a pipeline
for your data if you're an r programmer
then this should look pretty familiar to
you and the design of this library was
actually inspired by r remember don't
ever try to force this into one of your
projects but do consider it as an option
that's all i've got please let me know
what do you think
do you like the way that method chaining
looks
is it more or less readable are copies
worth it for immutability
or would you just prefer to avoid it
let me know with a comment
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me
if you especially enjoy my videos please
consider becoming a patron on patreon
enjoy your day coding and don't forget
to slap that like button an odd number
of times see you next time